do you think that's maybe hindered you
in dating because part of femininity is
relinquishing control yeah yeah and and
so if we're always taught we can't count
on men men are like okay then why would
we sign up because men men want to be
needed yeah yeah they do and so if they
don't feel like they're needed they
don't have purpose yeah that's why I may
I had like a really bad choices in my
relationship because then I I present
myself like the independent woman strong
woman that doesn't need anything from
anyone and then you know mental like
yeah so what what why am I here well I'm
here like but I I think it can be both
because I'm that very independent woman
I work my butt off I've done everything
I needed to do for myself and I'm aware
that I don't need anyone but that's not
to say that I don't want someone to do
those things
when a guy approaches you and he's
interested in you but you're not
interested in that guy well it's if I'm
not interested in them I'm not
interested
there needs to be no but there needs to
be an attraction first off or you know
something that's intrigued me about you
and then obviously like I said I'm not
shut off to it I'm just celibate right
now yeah like I'm not shut off to it and
the guy that you're attracted to comes
in the room but he doesn't approach you
what are you gonna do approach him yeah
I mean cool
I mean it's like this me personally I
feel like it's about what you bring to
the table it's like yeah for example
it's like
you should definitely rely to a man if
you're filling in the gaps but if you
now like for example let's say he's just
focused on money and he's just solely
the provider I feel like you should be
taking care of other areas because you
already provided for if you now you want
to be at home and rely on a man he's a
pimp he's a simple pimp simp whatever
you want to call it he's is not a fair
bargain so in that aspect you shouldn't
rely on a man but you have to listen to
something else he pays every single
thing now you financially you don't
worry about a single thing needs to be
balanced balance is really really
important like yeah
um don't get it wrong I love being
independent I do everything for myself
but
I think they should be fairness like I
ain't hung up my bra if I was to meet
someone and settle down with that person
for example if I was to get married and
have more children and I'm at home and
I'm raising those children then I'm
probably not going to go out to work
because I'm raising the kids right that
makes sense so I'm gonna do the
household duties and he's gonna be the
provider which is fair that's what I
think exactly you know I'm saying
there's balance
and to solely provide on a man if I'm
not having kids and I'm not doing
anything well that would kind of make me
lazy he's getting the short end of the
stick so I have a question what do you
guys feel like you could bring to a guy
that he couldn't just hire a maid and a
hooker to do
that's a good I made a cook and a hooker
to do so basically you need kids kids is
the only thing yeah I'm sorry to
interrupt but it's kids
no it's true but I just wanted to put
that out no it's true yeah but just
before any we knew that yeah cool
I feel like you have to match his energy
like if you if you're trying to chase
someone that has got all this drive and
ambition to be the best and they're
putting in the hours at work you also
need to be of a similar
person like you need to have that
similar personality no because men men
and women look for different things so
like men don't care about your money
they don't care about your career they
don't think no they don't care about
they don't care about what you do but I
think you still need to do that for
yourself I mean you can do what makes
you happy yeah but it doesn't but no
okay that's terrified no so you're right
you're right actually you're correct
you're correct but I'm saying like like
don't complain about the results though
so if you want to do what makes you
happy don't complain about the results
yeah so like I mean you can you can you
can like become the guy but like men
don't like guys they like women that are
like some men like guys yeah it's not
you've done two yings yeah it won't fit
together or two yangs it don't work
so your question is what do we bring to
the table Yeah man calling it from a
maid or yeah like from a from a mate
like made cook and a hooker a paid
service I was gonna yeah some hookers
provide emotional safety into intimacy
companionship there are loads of men
that I talk to that are like Linda do
you know what sometimes I think my
partner doesn't understand that I need
someone to talk to I need someone who I
can feel vulnerable to without her
throwing it back in my face
yo all right so you said men shouldn't
um they are they go to their women or
they're they're worried about what you
said it again sorry so basic wait what
so I think what days yeah the
vulnerability they want to they want
their partner to they want to feel safe
to be vulnerable without her throwing it
back in their face when they have an
argument okay so those men should not be
emotional to their women because it's in
female nature to
if let's say there's an argument between
a man and a woman if she has ammo there
is no line that she wants us and men
arguing between men there are lines they
understand I cannot respect exactly I
can't speak about his mother otherwise
all War break loose however if I'm
arguing with a woman
and the last time she said she she came
over it there's no boundaries and so the
solution is that men should go and speak
to their male friends
about situations that are emotional to
them that are deep to them and then once
they've come up with Solutions with
their male friends they should go and
have the solutions ready for their woman
ish that's easier said than done because
I agree I actually ran a room on this on
clubhouse about this whole dynamic and
Men also said that they don't always
feel safe to speak about really
emotional things because they don't even
know how because it makes them feel less
of a guy in front of their guy that's
not really okay
but I agree that was the most common
response then my solution to that is if
you don't feel comfortable having a
conversation with your guy friends then
go to an elder like this is an encore
father figure where they're not in the
same
dynamical group settings they've done
life they've been there done that got
the t-shirt and that way you can have a
conversation with them that will allow
you to feel that oh even if I I could
feel less of a man if I'm talking to a
guy that's been there he's he's done
things that I could never imagine you
know what I'm saying that's what so what
so if a guy doesn't want to be
emotionally vulnerable he says I got my
boys for that what could you offer him
me personally yeah
I want to lie and say peace of mind
[Laughter]
but do you know what yeah I'm learning I
don't mind being like honest yeah I'm
learning that sometimes we just need to
shut up as women like no no no like yeah
yeah honestly like we need to shut up I
like I'm guilty of this because
sometimes I can get so emotional and I'm
just like wait hold on
it's not really that big of a deal let
me just take a step back and I get more
of a positive outcome when I'm a little
bit more logical with yeah a man that
I'm romantically involved with that when
I'm all over the place and then the
second thing is listen because often
times yeah men really are telling us
what the issue is what the problem is
and then we take a we take like
girls
and he's like but you've missed
everything I was trying to say your
peace of mind if we could do that we can
offer that that a hoe and the other ones
can't do
what do you guys think I do agree with
that I think listening is so important
yeah because they will men will tell you
yeah and the more time you don't listen
yeah you just don't because you you want
to hear what you want to hear yeah
what suits you what makes you feel good
you feel me so we don't listen that's
very true I'm not saying I'm not gonna
say everyone
yeah bombarded but yeah I think there's
a big percentage of women that don't
listen we don't listen and we talk on
top of men as well we talk over them
as well I think we need to allow men to
be men and women need to be women and I
think yeah yeah that is something that's
so important there's too many women
trying to be that are trying to be men
that's me what do you think no that's I
like your others you're not you're not
alone that's like a common um roller
tomasi always says women become the men
they want to marry yeah so they get good
with their finances they get in shape
they do all the things that they want
yeah in a guy would you say yeah that's
what happened to me basically but my
relationship went down in the toilet
because
I was the man like I wasn't even allowed
them to pay for dinner or offer me a
dinner
I'll do that you want to go out on a
weekend I'll pay how long did I lost
well the last one's just six months
yeah there was much control B yeah I
know I know now
I went in that healing process yeah
I'm gonna make a point yeah I did I
didn't wear in Spain I didn't wear on a
holiday with my girlfriend yeah I just
no I just know where they're going I
think think no I I no no I just came
here in London and I was like you know
what I think there's something's wrong
with me
it's not me that I'm like it's not that
other people are it's our accountability
that's me probably I'm being a prick as
well as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible